hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game that was played today
in the chest 24 banter blitz session
well not a band tribute session is
basically the banter blitz Cup between
our stronger Grandmaster from Azerbaijan
our alpha handoff and magnus carlsen and
while I'm still preparing the the Paul
Morphy saga the whole first American
chess congress I would just like to
invite you to acquire the book that I'm
currently reading if you have the
opportunity it's a David Lawson's book
and Paul Morphy the pride and sorrow of
chess it's really really amazing I feel
like I should really read up a bit more
before I continue I mean I'm gonna
continue the saga tomorrow but it's just
it's an it's a really awesome book and
you will not be sorry David Lawson spent
his entire life basically researching
Paul Morphy and he published the book
like when he was 87 years old so it's
basically his life's work and it's just
written very well and there's so much
information on Paul Morphy
I will only disclose a little bits of
information during the Paul Morphy saga
but if you're really interested try and
acquire the book you will not be storing
now that being said let's check out this
very nice game so Magnus started by
losing two games in this in this match
he was better he was basically winning
in both games but in the end Mamadou was
able to flag him so he lost on time as
these are three minute blitz games so
this is a game for where Magnus had the
black pieces and he again employs his uh
well he's weird Queen to East six kinda
Navion so let's see what happens efore
d5 again cross and goes for his
Scandinavian Queen captures on d5 Knight
c3 and now as you know there are a
couple of possible retreats Queen d8
went a five Queen to d6 very popular
nowadays but here Queen to east sex with
check and it's a really weird move you
put a queen blocking your own epon
but as I said it's a three minute blitz
game why not give it a go
so Knight GT to Bishop to e2 is a busy
normal reply here followed by Knight of
three in castles but this is what the
moment of tried in the second game and
even though he won that game Magnus was
winning in the end but he didn't like
the position he got so he's trying this
gt2 idea here and here some moves have
been played here but here Knight to f6
is basically a new move so as a move
forward we have a completely new game
which is not surprising if you if you
look at where the Queen's at but okay we
have d4 by Mahmoud of ending out b6 now
preparing to develop the light square
bishop also keep an eye on the d5 square
so mama dog immediately pushes d5 before
Bishop to b7 makes it impossible Queen
back to d7 now okay you lost temple you
will be able to maybe challenge this
pawn later with a 6 or c6 and now Knight
f4 as what black will now pile up on the
d5 pawn you want to have it nicely
protected now with Bishop to b7 and now
Bishop to c4 now again defending and c6
now challenging the central pawn with
castles by Mahmud off and just see
captures on d5 we have night F capture
Sun d5 Knight character Sun d5 Knight
captures on d5 ending out just the
knight to c6 continuing development
preparing to Castle queenside we have
Bishop to f4 and and out comes a
queenside castle we have Knight back to
c3 offering a queen trade and now Magnus
was thinking about a queen Queen to a5
attacking the bishop and opening up an
attack towards the Queen which were
basically force Bishop to b2 but in the
end he decides knife to d4 is a stronger
idea again
you now have opportunities to move the
Queen and then you will have a nice
discovery from the rook to the Queen and
here Bishop the d5 is the only good move
for white because you open up and attack
towards the knight now and well you have
to go back 96 characters captures and
then you go Queen for example to g4 and
the game continues it's not bad for
black black can go in a rook to d4 and
so on so it's a very much a playable
position but here mom and went f3 and
here he gives a Magnus a very very good
move but Magnus decides to go the other
way here Queen to f5 is just so strong
Queen to f5 and there is no good reply
for white because well the bishop is
under attack and the relative move the
bishop just Knight captures on f3 check
picks up the Queen so basically we would
have to
give it up this way captures captures
and you can even capture in situ I would
with a completely winning game so after
Queen to five you really don't have a
good reply here you could go Knight to
d5 not saying okay if you capture with
the bishop I'm going to capture the
night here but basically we just grab
two pieces for a rook so yeah we would
have this game but okay crossing goes
for Queen to c6 again with a similar
idea now you can move the night and
again expose this attack but Bishop to
d3 now just closing it so now here Quinn
to cease it was a bit inferior to Queen
to a5 but okay Queen c5 now again
threatening some nasty discoveries and
the King to h1 and finally he five I
move you are always looking to play when
you play the Scandinavian the Shabak the
e3 now pinning the Knight and King to b8
I'm just getting the cooking away from
some nasty diagonals with quinta II one
getting the Queen away from from the D
file and the now f6 just strengthening
in the center we have a four by white
now now wanting to start an attack bust
open the Kings position and now a5
Magnus prevents white from pushing a5
but he allows the Knights to be 5 in
this night here is now a really strong
piece guarding a7 c7 so the King doesn't
really have all that many squares any
checks along for example this diagonal
could be could be deadly if it opens up
and also it just puts more pressure to
the night here c3 is an idea which we
just may win material so Magnus has to
move the Queen and now Bishop the e4
again harassing the Queen Queen to d7
and here you could continue with adding
the pressure with rook to d1 which which
definitely makes sense for example rule
D 1 C 3 is coming well not not all other
things black can do here but here
Mammadov instead playing Bishop
characters on b7 again it's a three-man
blitz game of course both players will
miss stuff and here Magnus decides that
recapturing should not be very favorable
to him for example the ship character
spawn characters Queen to g3 check and
then oh well you just have to calculate
a lot of things in a
unpleasant situations so instead after
Bishop captures an b7 Magnus goes for
night captures and c2 now attacks the
rook and the Queen and now well he's
down a piece but you know things are
things are in motion so what happens
here we have Queen to c3 now again you
could capture the room but Magnus goes
for an even better night captures an e3
which again comes with an attack on the
roof so he wins back the piece still is
still attacking the rook we have Bishop
to c6 now attacking the Queen and here
Bishop to b4 now forcing if you capture
here I'm gonna capture here so here at
Mammadov captures the knight instead and
now comes Queen captures and c6 so it's
remarkable how long the Queen's remain
on the board because there was an
opportunity to trade Queens plenty of
times throughout the game which is
something I of course always welcome
makes the game more enjoyable we look 8a
c1 now brings the rook into the attack
and now Bishop to c5
the only good move if you move the Queen
not really a lot of good things are
coming you also have to keep an eye on
the b6 pawn so Bishop to c5 is an
automatic basically we have Queen back
the c3 in the now rook to d7 both
players very low and time Magnus is
preparing to double up rooks on the D
file and here you should you should
contest to the file which rook to d1 but
for for some reason Queen to c4 is
played here by Mammadov and the Magnus
immediately offers a queen trade with
Queen to d5 he did consider bringing the
rook here but he said okay first we're
gonna do this
Queen to g4 getting the Queen out of
harm's way put some pressure under on
the point if the rook stops defending it
and also maybe if the Queen moves ideas
maybe like wintery six followed by well
not captures right away but maybe some
ideas with sacrificing the the rook and
then capturing and b6 could be nice
so rook H to d8 by Magnus and now h3
giving the King some breathing room and
now comes Queen to d2 now putting
pressure on the pawn here and well it's
just a very tough position for white you
can never play rook to d1 why well black
could even even give up
Queen for to Brooks I don't think it'd
be a problem so night back to c3 here
Quinta a6 is actually a decent tribe now
you're already threatening rogue
characters and c5 followed by Queen
Queen to b6 but so you would not be able
to capture a pond you would have to go
back for example Queen to d5 and then
let's say Queen back to g4 so maybe this
way Mammadov could force Magnus to try a
different idea but instead after Queen
to d2 he goes back Knight to c3 and
Magnus just picks up a pawn and also he
frees the the d2 square for the rook if
needed
we have night Stewie for threatening to
pick up the bishop but now Bishop to e3
of course not allowing it the rupee's
under attack rook the b1 and now Queen
to c2 so you still cannot capture the
bishop nicely defends it from e3 so it's
not a problem but now Queen to East six
again threatening rock actress and be
silly because now the Queen joins the
action King to East a seven just
defending the b7 pawn now twice with the
bishop and the king and now Queen back
to g4 bringing the Queen back into the
defense but now Magnus just crushes down
rook to d1 we route captures rook
captures and now first Queen characters
in g7 with check King to a6 and now we
have another trade character's captures
and now as this comes with check King to
h2 and now we reach a very interesting
position where both letters are
extremely low one-time and Magnus
already lost two games where mama dog
was able to flag him but that's why I'm
gonna ask you to pause the video here
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for black here while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's a it's a very
important checkmate pattern for you to
know and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show the cleanest way is
Queen to e 1 and Magnus played Bishop
therefore check which is winning but
being very long time it would be it
would be just more reasonable to go
Queen to eat the Queen to e1 because
after Queen to e1 there is no defense
you got the the g3 square so the King
cannot escape and
doesn't really matter what white plays
it's pretty pointless whatever you play
with say queen g4 or something just
Bishop to g1 check and it's game over
you have to go back in each one of the
shop to f2 you open a discovery from the
Queen now the King has to move once
again and Queen to g1 will be made so
this is what you want to do after King
h2 but of course with with little time
on the clock or all calculation is more
than unnecessary so Magnus instead was
Bishop to f4 check and now Mammadov
makes it easy for him by playing g3 if
he went night to g3 this is also
completely winning for black as the
night will never move again due to the
the pin here and well basically you just
capture this pawn go back like Queenie
one let's say you you trade everything
and the King and pawn and game is of
course winning you just Queen the Queen
side pawn there's there is no question
about it however you are a very long
time that's why the Queen e1 maneuver
was preferable but okay here at Mammadov
instead when the g3 of course they both
know that an IG 3 is completely losing
but now again it's just Queen e2 check
King h1 Queen captures on f3 with chef
Kings you want and Bishop to e3 check
and it was in this position that rough
mama don't resign the game and with this
victory Magnus equalized in the match
and it's now 2 to 2
so yeah here you resign because King H
to Queenie to check you go back in h1
Queen f1 check here and this is now mate
so of course there's no no need to
complete it but yeah I just wanted you
guys to see this Queen to e1 maneuver
you should remember this bishop here the
Queen has to be anyone guarding these
two squares and the bishop has to be
controlling this diagonal so you might
have this opportunity in your own games
and you will know that Bishop the g1
always leads to mate if the position is
well yes like it is here I even had this
position I think like two years ago
against the candidate master and I had
this position similar not this one but
the pattern was similar and I didn't
spot it immediately even though it was a
classical game I think was like an hour
hour each and then I found that I was
like well this was here all the time and
well so you should know it it's one of
the the
and mating patterns but yeah I like I
said that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I will put a link to all the
games from the match to match a the
match ended eight and a half to four and
a half in cousins favor which which is
which is quite nice you know considering
the openings used so if you want to
check it all out
Magnus himself was streaming so you can
also enjoy that I will put a link to it
will be the first thing you'll see in
the description below and yeah that's
pretty much it I would like to think
then it's Billings J Roland Michael's
nucleus ski run got a shot in the David
Kaiser for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga and of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday